a British diver who heroically saved
young soccer players from a flooded cave
in Thailand had to be rescued himself
Josh Brackley was part of an elite team
of divers who helped save the 12 boys
and their coach last year on Tuesday he
got trapped in a flooded cave in
Tennessee broccoli was stranded for
nearly 30 hours without food or water
meg Oliver spoke to the diver who
rescued him last night she is in Jackson
County meg good morning good morning the
cave is located about a mile down that
road on private property Bradley was
reported missing around 1:00 a.m.
Wednesday morning officials called in
dive experts from out of state we spoke
with the first rescuer to arrive he
ventured into the cave alone not knowing
if he'd find Bradley alive Josh Bradley
and four other divers were exploring a
cave more than 60 miles northeast of
Nashville Tuesday Bradley got separated
from the group losing contact with the
rope guiding him through water so muddy
there was zero visibility Bradley is not
just an experienced cave diver he was a
member of the elite group of British
rescuers in July who successfully pulled
12 youth soccer players in their coach
from a flooded cave in Thailand but now
Bradley was trapped in a cave that
presented special challenges it's just a
lot of ups and downs jagged rock turns
silty low low low visibility ed Sorensen
was one of the rescuers called in from
Arkansas in Florida
first to arrive he decided not to wait
to enter the cave the whole time I was
looking up in all the crevices was a
little visibility I had looking for a
body because I where actually found his
way to an open space the water around
him was 40 feet deep but he climbed to a
shelf in the cave with a roof about
seven feet above him when you first saw
him what did he look
he was covered head-to-toe but he looks
I mean there wasn't a spot on his body
that wasn't by his face was muddy his
helmet was muddy Bradley had been
trapped for more than a day but Sorenson
guided him out in less than an hour so
this must have been such a role reversal
for him how did he handle it very well
cave diving is about 80% mental he was
very calm one of the next things he said
to me was my friends are never gonna let
me live this down and I said at least
you're here to not live it down
Bradley was evaluated by doctors on the
scene but appeared alert and awake and
refused any medical treatment he had
just one request he wanted some pizza
Nora
Meg thank you I like pizza too I don't
have to be rescued from a cave I don't
understand cave diving guys I'm just
glad he's okay he says his friends will
tease him but at least he's here to tell
the story sorry